[MUSIC]
>> Through his compassionate
inquisitiveness and his care for others,
this professor truly embodies
what makes the GSB special.
It is for all of these reasons that now
ask you to join us in congratulating
the 2018 recipient of the distinguished
teaching award Professor Amit Seru.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [SOUND] Thank you everyone on
the committee for
those kind words and the award.
It's obviously a great honor
to join the illustrious
colleagues who have won
this award before me.
I want to especially thank
the Talk to the Hat group,
my MBA2s from last year,
you know who you are.
We weren't largest in numbers, but
you all sure did make a loud noise.
And thank you for making the noise,
and making me feel this appreciated.
Those were very generous and kind words,
but I want to start by thanking my wife,
who's there.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And
kids, actually, because innovation in
teaching, it starts at home, actually.
Because most of the times I've realized,
when I've tried to teach them anything,
it doesn't work.
But in the words of famous Rocky Balboa,
it's not about how hard you hit,
it's about how you can get hit and
then still keep moving forward.
And that's what I try to do.
Though I'm still looking for
success at home,
with this award,
I'm hoping that I can point to some
more credibility than I have now,
hopefully that'll work.
I have to say that you all
attributed too much credit to me.
I would be amiss if I didn't
thank my finance colleagues,
specially those who helped shape
the change in the curriculum and
allowed us to think about these things.
Professor Josh Rauh, Hanno Lustig, and
Peter DeMarzo in particular, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And other colleagues, like Tim McQuid,
who have gone ahead and
implemented these changes.
But, to be honest, all of these changes
cannot happen without all of you here.
All of you have been very gracious,
in your thoughts, in your inputs,
in your feedback.
Been very patient in both absorbing and
acknowledging things that have worked and
things that haven't worked.
But this is the tolerance for failure,
which leads to a lot of innovation.
Not only in the classroom,
but in the real world.
And so, I hope that you will
continue to be patient,
because that's going to
lead to more innovation.
Which is something that we always want.
Now, I should note, that if there
is any innovation that's working,
it's obviously the work
of my colleagues and me.
And, if it's not working, it's because
of the feedback from all of you.
But more seriously,
in the finance classes I have taught,
I have emphasized thinking about
economic tradeoffs, incentives.
And I have suggested that the simplest
way to think about this is
the Micky Mouse balance sheet.
Which those who have taken my class
know what I am talking about.
And thinking about the MM framework.
Now, you know, knowing where the freak
come from and where they go.
But these are interesting frameworks,
but if you think about the big picture,
which I like to sort of talk
about in all of my classes,
we are at very interesting times,
at crossroads, really.
And that requires us to take
all of these frameworks that
you're learning in finance or
other classes and push them, really,
in directions that we haven't
sort of really tested.
So, business, government policy, society,
they're all interacting in ways,
and making changes at a pace,
that we haven't seen before.
There's disruption, innovation, but they
are disrupted, and a large number of them.
There is growth, but
there is also polarization.
And then there's government, which is
trying to balance all of these different
constituents, sometimes successfully,
sometimes not so much.
And, in this ecosystem,
in this environment, the question for
you all, like the committee posed,
they stole my thunder,
is how are you going to define success.
What's success for you?
It could be about innovating.
It could be about
generating free cashflows,
making money, a lot of jobs, growth.
But I'm hoping that you'll be more
fearless coming out of GSB, and
I'm going to push this
a little bit further.
And when you do that, free cash flows
are not going to be free anymore.
It'll require you to challenge yourselves,
and
redefine what you mean by success,
pretty regularly, really.
And when you do, I'm hoping, that when you
go out from GSB, you will come back and
give us inputs and
feedback, like you have while you
were here, so that you challenge us.
Because that's the only way we build
knowledge stock on which the next
generations can really build on.
And, you know, I like to call it
standing on the shoulders of giants,
which is all of you and us, where next
generations can stand and look far.
But I was at a Midwest GST where I was
told, No, no no, that is old school.
The new thing is you're standing
on the shoulders of dinosaurs.
Because then you can see even further.
So whatever, you guys need to go out and
then come back, and
let us know what are we doing right and
what are we not doing wrong.
But the bottom is that the problems
are complex and the solutions are unknown.
But my hope is that all of you
who have taken my classes, and
we have learned together,
are going to use some of this.
And, as you are going to be figuring
out the answers, which will help us to
together, change lives, change
organizations, and change the world,
to make it a better place than what
you and I got when we sort of started.
So with that, again, thank you, everyone.
Really appreciate it.
And this is going to be a very memorable
day for many years to come for me.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]